[Musik]
alle herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt einen kuchen klassiker aus
der russischen küche dieses rezept wurde
schon sehr sehr oft angefragt der
napoleon kuchen der polier kuchen ist
wirklich und klassiker aus der
russischen küche er besteht aus vielen
einzelnen teigschichten die
teigschichten sind so eine art mini
folge also ein bisschen blätterteig
artig der blätterteig muss aber nicht
geschichtet und gefaltet und geburt
werden sondern ich zeige euch gleich wie
man den super einfach herstellt und dann
kommt da eine creme hinein und die macht
das ganz einfach war richtig lecker ich
habe den napoleon kuchen selbst auch
schon mal gegessen aber ist echt schon
jahre her zubereitet habe ich ihn
tatsächlich noch nicht das heißt heute
premiere ich zeige euch mal die zutaten
für den teig dafür nehme ich 500 gramm
mehl und einen teelöffel backpulver oder
ihr nehmt einfach 500 gramm backen eine
prise salz 250 gramm eiskalte butter 1
ei und 200 milliliter eiskaltes wasser
also wichtig ist wirklich das futter und
wasser eiskalt am besten nehmen wir euch
jetzt ein mixer und in mixa ich hab da
diese mix messer mit drin wichtig ist
nämlich dass der teig schön kalt bleibt
das heißt ihr gebt jetzt hier oben das
meer ein
dann kommt das salz dazu
und die butter ist ganz ganz kalt ich
hatte sie auch noch mal im
gefrierschrank
einfach in würfeln dazu geben falls
jetzt keinen mixa besitzt könnt ihr auch
zum beispiel mit einem teig zur hackert
arbeiten so dass die butter schön kalt
bleibt also am besten nicht mit den
händen kneten weil dann wird schon sehr
weich und das war jetzt nicht so gut
und die mutter soll jetzt nämlich in
stücke noch bleiben also jetzt nicht
komplett vermissen sondern immer wieder
auf puls drücken oder eben an und
ausschalten und so weit arbeiten dass
das mehl mit der butter so ein bisschen
verbunden ist aber die butter noch
kleine stückchen hat denn das und später
detail geschichten oder die butter
schichten die den teig so aufgehen
lassen
[Musik]
da könnt ihr hier das ein mit dem wasser
verrühren
[Musik]
das mache ich jetzt einfach schon mal
dass ich den teig nicht so lange kneten
muss deswegen hier die zutaten vorher
verrühren und
stand da oben dazugeben und noch mal
ganz kurz durchwachsen aber
nicht zu meinen
[Musik]
den rest werde ich jetzt mit den händen
verkneten aber auch hier wirklich noch
ganz ganz leicht und vorsichtig
[Musik]
als ich knete hierbei gar nicht sondern
drücke den teig einfach zusammen so dass
alles sich gut verbindet aber trotzdem
diese kleinen butter stückchen dem jetzt
hier auch sehen kann noch vorhanden sind
das war's schon und dann nehme ich mir
jetzt einen kuchen einteiler und portion
ihre zwölf teile
und die form tier dann jeweils zu einer
kugel
hatte hauptsache gleich mehr situationen
ihr könnt auch mehrere machen dann habt
ihr mehr als zwölf schichten denn das
ist im prinzip das was am aufwändigsten
ist dass man eben diese schichten
einzelnen backen muss im ofen aber dafür
hat man eben dann diese tollen
geschichten in der torte das lohnt sich
schon auf jeden fall
ist hier einfach zu kugeln
zusammenfassen
die gebe ich jetzt hier einfach in eine
schüssel rhein kann sie abdecken und
dann kommen die für mindestens eine
stunde in den kühlschrank
damit der teig noch mal schön kalt
werden kann und die zeit kann ich nutzen
hier kurz aufräumen und dann schon mal
die füllung vorbereiten
dafür nehme ich 200 gramm 11.30
kampfstärke etwas wandel extrakt zweige
eine dose kondensmilch das ist so eine
gezuckerte karamell kondensmilch und 300
gramm weiche butter ihr seht jetzt auch
schon dass ich keinen zucker hier habe
weder im teig noch in der creme der
einzige zucker den ich habe ist
praktisch in der kondensmilch und dazu
gereicht auch also die ist wirklich sehr
süß und es gibt eine kondensmilch dies
einfach nur gezuckert und es gibt diese
karamell kondensmilch und mit der
karamell kondensmilch ist der geschmack
schon noch mal ein bisschen besser es
gebe ich hier ein bisschen milch rein
dann die stärke
wandel extrakt muss natürlich im
original ich weiß ist kein mann in
extrakt aber dass selbst die sally
version da kommt ein extrakt drin
denn die eigelbe
jetzt kurz klümpchen frei verrühren und
jetzt wirklich die ganze zeit hören
sonst gibt's bündchen
falls sie übrigens neue kennwort habt zu
einer cooking chef mit dieser funktion
dann könnt ihr den pudding auch direkt
darin kochen am besten dann auf 90 95
grad stellen und die maschine einfach
hören lassen dann müsst ihr nicht am
herd stehen ständig rühren es kann
nichts anbrennen nichts über kochen es
entstehen keine klümpchen
weil hier hat muss man schon ständig
über nun aufpassen aber von kurzen
moment ist es auch okay
das braucht jetzt auch gleich und dann
geht s recht relativ schnell
als das passt wirklich gut auf
geht's eigentlich ein vogel
kann man update von oben
ja
heute schon den vogel wieder gegen die
scheibe genau und geflogen und dann lag
der da jetzt mal den in so einem karton
mit löchern reihen auf dem tuch er hat
sich nämlich nicht mehr bewegt und wir
hoffen er schlägt wieder weiter
vielleicht ist nur in schockstarre aber
wir mussten information hätten deswegen
muss man ihn vom boden wegnehmen
jetzt kommt eine kleine raubkatze
braucht sich dann vogel
[Musik]
am ende müssen wirklich aufpassen bei
sondern problem dar doch so wirklich
sehr schnell
und findet pudding dann ein mal
aufgekocht tops dann ist er fertig
jetzt kann es passieren dass es durch
ihn gebildet haben das ist gar nicht
schlimm dann streicht ihnen einfach
durch ein feines sieb und
ich mach das jetzt hier direkt auf
sondern im mai teller oder kühlt dann
nämlich auch recht schnell ab
im mai besitzt nämlich die fähigkeit die
temperatur sofort abzugleichen und
abzuleiten
ja immer durch streichen
[Musik]
und hier auf dem teller kann der pudding
jetzt schön abkühlen und ich kann in der
zwischenzeit hier schon mal die butter
verrühren und dies jetzt auch schön
weich
das sieht man jetzt hier ganz gut und da
gebe ich dann gleich die karamell
kondensmilch dazu okay das seit sehr
unästhetisch aus aber
der komcom süd später gut aus
[Musik]
und wenn die mutter dann weiß cremig ist
kommt die karamell creme dazu
ihr seht ihr hier jetzt auch schon
manchmal die muss kurz durchrühren
einmal durchführen und checken
die normale kondensmilch gezuckerten bis
in die flüssig und die hier ist schon
relativ fest und die ist echt ganz gut
ich glaube der mogat mag auch das ist
eine karamell drehen wird
diese kondensmilch und die karamell
kondensmilch die gibt es eigentlich in
gut sortierten supermärkten entweder in
der russischen abteilung oder auch
mittlerweile in der normalen bank
abteilung da könnt ihr mal schauen und
da gibt es einfach auf verschiedene
marken dir nehmen könnt achtet nur
wirklich darauf dass es die dickflüssige
ist und das erkennt man natürlich außen
an der verpackung nicht aber da steht
dann eben darauf entweder karamell
kondensmilch oder gezuckerte
kondensmilch und es ist wichtig denn die
normale kondensmilch ist so flüssig und
damit eure cremig fest also kurz weiß
cremig rühren und die kondensmilch und
dann den pudding dazu rühren
[Musik]
die buttercreme spd
und sie sieht wundervoll aus
guckt mal
richtig schön geschmeidig tolle farbe
und die stelle ich jetzt abgedeckt zur
seite nicht in den kühlschrank die soll
jetzt nicht kalt werden die darf ruhig
bleiben und der teig ist jetzt
mittlerweile auch gekühlt das heißt
jetzt geht's ans schichten backen
das dauert jetzt leider am meisten zeit
[Musik]
du stehst auf meinem platz
und im 800 m hoch auf den hocker genau
bis zum anschlag sind die hände
gewaschen
mit seife
das brauchen wir okay da teig ist das
carls und jetzt werden die einzelnen
teile ausgerollt
ich mache auch matschie als ihr
besonderes video
jetzt einfach mit wenig mühe hatte ich
zeige dir das erstmal
da darf jetzt nicht weich werden nein
nicht knete
mit wenig mehl ausrollen und am besten
direkt auf einer bank folie
relativ dünn
nachdem ich aus
es steht jetzt auch die abstandsregel
noch wegnehmen
ok es doch es wird lustig
dann rechts immer nicht nach plan
[Musik]
willst du eigentlich auch mal wieder was
backen und eigenes rezept
ja was denn
[Musik]
der kuchen mit sahne häubchen okay aber
das ist keine etwa zeit
kleiner kam ja ich suche gleich
also ihr seht schon datei lässt sich
wunderbar ausrollen und er arbeitet
jetzt wirklich nicht wenig mehl und holt
in aber auch kinder und rollt ihn aber
so dünn es geht aus angst was haben
erwartet dass muss gleich in den
backofen
nur zum ausrollen jetzt wird es ganz
kurz
nach fortschritten bei nokia dass das
jetzt ein polier und orte
sonst auch so
solltet mal darauf dann brav ich dein
platz
mattel hatte langsam nicht so schnell
gucken wir immer ein bisschen wir wollen
ja einen kreis und nicht italien
und damit wenig italien bekommen müssen
wir den teig immer mal drehen so
das war schon aus wie so ein stiefel wie
die landkarte von italien
13 wenn jetzt noch mal drei war
ja stopp und dann immer einer vor einmal
zurück was ja immer gucken dass darunter
mehl ist
das aber jetzt in russischer kuchen jaja
da war es schlecht weil es eine italien
karte machen wenn damit der russland
karte form
so noch mal um mitgefühl guck mal gar
nicht drücken immer noch mit gefühl
[Musik]
und
ich wollte sagen der auswahl starb hat
ja auch ein eigenes gewicht deswegen
muss man gar nicht drücken also du
kannst dir die kräfte sparen
naja jetzt es wieder schön dünn
und nächster zeit ja so dünn wie papier
fliegt fast weg aber jetzt gucken wir
mal wie groß das ist und ich denke wir
stellen uns jetzt auf 22 zentimeter aus
gucken ob wir das hinkriegen
ja
genau
da passt noch nicht ganz
so
passt ich will drückt oder wenig
bewegung und
den rest drumherum lassen wir aber
liegen denn das werden später die krümel
die brauchen wir so
[Musik]
was soll's jetzt schon wieder ich habe
angst
also ihr lebenspraktisch euren teig und
schaut immer dass er ungefähr auf die
gleiche größe kommt dann aus stechen
geht auch mit einem teller da braucht
jetzt kein tortenring dafür
ganz vorsichtig so bekommt der teig
schon mal eine schöne runde form der
strom rum lassen war aber alles liegen
denn das brauchen wir später durch
krümel und
jetzt kommen die ersten schon mal in den
backofen den habe ich schon vorgeheizt
auf 190 grad heißluft so kann ich zwei
stücke immer gleichzeitig backen und in
der zeit in der zeit mache ich die
übrigen das kind bringt mich 2000 haben
soll
nein nein die brauchen wir hier
das können wir gleich mit einem anderen
tag machen aber nicht mit meinem napoli
und
kennst du napoleon bonaparte
wie ich meine nicht seiner partei
im geschichtsunterricht bald geht's
schon zur schule
[Musik]
ich mach mal sechs minuten und schaue
einfach ob sich die farbe schön
verändert goldbraun sollten zu sein
nicht zu dunkel und nicht zu hell das
heißt kommt bisschen auf eurem backofen
treffern ja was schaust du
okay allah ist weg jetzt gibt es einmal
eine richtige anleitung
dies kurz drüben nase kommt nicht mehr
ok also ein bisschen mehr nehmen und
dann den teig schön dünn ausrollen und
ich mache das jetzt auch direkt auf der
dauer back pole ihr könnt auch
backpapier verwenden ist es einfach nur
wichtig da teig wird er gleich so dünn
gewollt dass er ihn einfach nicht mehr
weg bewegen könnt das heißt einfach
direkt auf der unterlage aus rollen auf
der ihr spacken werden ich habe eben
schon einen schritt vergessen nämlich
den teig einzustechen es ist ganz
wichtig dass der sich nicht welt im ofen
war sobald die ella dazu kommt das
bringt mich manchmal mittel aus dem
konzept die ist nämlich so lustig und
hat immer quatschen kopf dass ich
aufpassen muss dass sie nicht mich und
andere hier im raum gefährdet und sie
selbst nicht in lebensgefahr bringt
[Musik]
und jetzt einfach mit einer gabel oder
mit einer tankkarte einstechen
damit der teig beim backen schön flach
bleibt und dann nacheinander backen
ich mag immer zwei gleichzeitig beim
speichern bisschen zeit
[Musik]
und nur 12 ich hab's geschafft ich hab's
gebacken es geht auch ex relativ
es ist ein einfacher kuchen aber es ist
natürlich zeitaufwendig ich meine ich
habe zwei backöfen parallel gearbeitet
immer zwei tage jeweils zehn minuten das
heißt dass zwölf bleche sechs mal zehn
minuten wenn ihr einen backofen habt
dann seid ihr ungefähr eine stunde am
backen wenn ihr zwei habt eben nur eine
halbe stunde aber ja zeitaufwand ist da
muss man viel warten aber der rest geht
eigentlich und ich habe jetzt immer
gleich das blech darunter weggezogen
damit der teig schnell abkühlt das geht
nämlich echt relativ fix und dann könnt
ihr die hier schön abkühlen lassen und
diese übrigen teile hier aufbewahrt und
jetzt geht es los mit dem schichten der
torte
wenn ich jetzt die ersten geschichten
mag bis dahin ist dann das auch kalt und
dann passt es
reizt mich hier immer ein bisschen was
von der buttercreme nehmen
und darauf streichen und den nächsten
kuchen und draufsetzen
[Musik]
jetzt ist der kuchen gefüllt und die
übrige creme streicht er jetzt einfach
noch obendrauf und bevor ich dann aber
mit dem dekorieren der torte
weitermachen stelle ich sie in den
kühlschrank weil ihr seht ihr jetzt auch
schon das verbot immer noch so ein
bisschen und dann lasse ich den kuchen
abgedeckt im kühlschrank ruhen für etwa
einer stunde dann wird die butter schön
fest und dann kann ich ihn aus deckung
werden
ich muss sagen wenn ich jetzt nicht die
originalversion machen wollen würde dann
hätte ich jetzt schon noch so ein
bisschen krokant mit reingepackt oder
andere zutaten die dem ganzen noch mal
einen intensiveren geschmack geben aber
ich glaube das wird noch so bestimmt
sehr lecker
noch ist das schief aber den krieg ich
schon gerade
jetzt ist die torte gut durch gekühlt
damit sieht auch am rand stellen glatt
wird denn sie es mir nicht glatt genug
werde ich sie noch mal zu schneiden
einmal so ansetzen
und dann hier
einfach wegstecken
[Musik]
das ist situation songs gleich
vernaschen
jetzt kann mit der übrigen creme alles
glatt gestrichen werden
werden die torte dann einigermaßen die
muss natürlich komplett platt sein wird
jetzt keine motiv torte aber wenn sie
jetzt einigermaßen glatt ist dann gibt
es die linken schrank bis auch jetzt die
äußere schicht buttercreme fest ist und
in der zwischenzeit kann ich mich schon
mal um die übrigen text krümmel kümmern
die müssen nämlich zerbröselt werden
und dann sieht man auch gleich nicht
mehr entschärfen
das macht hier echt gar nix
auch wenn es gegen meinen
gegen mein morgen da sein spricht ich
packte jetzt bisschen von dem
weggeschnitten weg dass ich es
ausgleichen
jetzt kekse bremsen
[Musik]
ich muss aber sagen dass mir das gleich
glaube ich zu langweilig wird somit den
bröseln ich werde noch bekannt dazu
geben weil ich glaube jetzt schmeckt ihr
das ganze eher neutral und nach karamell
buttercreme gutes sehr mag wird jetzt
schon schreien der mag nämlich
buttercreme aber ich werde auch ich mein
programm dazu oder machen wir schon ein
bisschen bisschen 'schon seines
irdischen
ich hätte auch noch keinen reingemacht
aber jetzt nicht zu abgefahren machen
[Musik]
ok das habe ich hier mein krokant und
für mich schon mit den kuchen brösel und
dann werden die an die torte dran
gedrückt
[Musik]
einfach hier mit so einer tankkarte oder
mit den händen können auch mit den
händen arbeiten
so schönen eindrücken
[Musik]
perfekt der napoleon kuchen ist fertig
und ich werde ihnen jetzt auf eine
tortenplatte setzen der muss jetzt
eigentlich noch normalerweise durch 10
für etwa vier bis sechs stunden damit
die böden die buttercreme schön
aufnehmen können gern auch über nacht
als das können auch gerne über nacht
kühl stellen ich muss mal gucken
ich glaub ich meinen gleich an ich
glaube wir halten es nicht durch bis
morgen
ja aber schneidet ihn gleich
[Musik]
die napoleon torte ist fertig und heute
darf ein richtiger general probieren
zwar reutlinger der erste ich bin gar
überholt
sagen das war keine kriegsverletzung
aber man kann
schon ein
jumbo verletzung wieder da ja ja
napoleon torte ganz so schlimm ist jetzt
mich aber schon doch die europäer aber
jetzt ist er wieder zurück zu uns nicht
noch ein bisschen aber es wäre
es ist das erste mal dass ich
tatsächlich was probieren und mit weiß
was es ist stimmt weil das so gesagt
hast du immer ja denn wir haben hier
hinter der kamera der zauber an dana ich
würde liebend weil ablöst die hat mich
den ganzen tag stehen muss und jetzt bin
ich mal gespannt also normalerweise
lässt man ich weiß gar nicht was ist mit
all dem trubel ja das ist jetzt erfahren
du als kaiser napoleon aber gut napoleon
hat jetzt nicht so den besten ruf
deswegen vergleicht ich jetzt nicht in
der
vorgeschichte ich kann das nicht sein
die tasche schon so ein bisschen sonne
sagt nichts dazu nur blamieren
ich habe es ja bei wikipedia gegoogelt
da kann es bei wikipedia gegoogelt
eigentlich nicht mal
nachgeschaut
lesen noch schreiben
ich bin ziemlich und ich habe den
gründer von wikipedia getroffen
normalerweise lässt man sie noch eine
nacht durch ziehen damit die schichten
weich werden aber es nicht so
übel ist gestorben zwölf schichten torte
erzeugt schicken
[Gelächter]
russisches rezept mit kondensmilch
locken das weiß dass viele diese
milchmädchen die heißt so diesem
problem
okay man muss aber nach durchziehen
lassen aber ich muss sagen dann hab ich
immer nur das auch nicht darf ich ja
[Musik]
es ist dann einen großen vorteil wenn
die nicht durchgezogen ist ein megatrend
es ist die
band schon kurz angst gehabt dass das so
ein kirschkern drin ist das ist der
klassiker ich bin immer kirschkuchen ein
kirschkern er war lecker
omega liga oben mit der karam and cremo
hat es das rucksack des genau am 1 das
wertvollste auf jeden fall näher und
aromatisch lecker
ich habe echt wir uns gedacht mir fehlt
war es weil es so theike und buttercreme
ok
[Gelächter]
weiß nicht wo am eine kranz der
hochzeitstorte eine die so schmeckt
krise
sind die böden zu verschieben und das
gemisch oder so alle alle gleich
hammer ist die aufwändig ich weiß
also man muss halt 12 böden backen das
zeitaufwendige arbeit ist einfach mögen
wirkliche auch ist einfach okay ist ja
einfachen können aber zeitaufwendig
markt also eine stunde am stück oder
eine halbe stunde wenn man zweifel haben
ich würde sagen mutig tatsächlich lohnt
sich wirklich general geprüft generali
osho ripplinger der erste hat geprüft
torte für gut befunden sehr gut bekomme
ich eine abzeichnung auszeichnung auch
in ordnung ich habe hier noch
okay okay weiß nicht warum ich habe
meine kamera dabei kommt er vorgefunden
mit der tat mit der torte so und einmal
so kaster kamera
das war schon das ja dies
könnte fast aus der zeit stammen
richtig schön also dann passiert sagt
gerne mal aus ich fand's hammer lecker
also wirklich wahnsinnig gut falls ihr
noch weitere russische spezialitäten
oder andere spezialitäten kennt nicht
unbedingt mal nachmachen soll dann
schreibt es doch gerne in die kommentare
gustav strohm mal was aus der russischen
küche gegessen
also been many habe ich schon mal
gemacht manche gibt es daher aus dem
türkischen das ja schon so ist ähnlich
aber
falls ihr noch weitere rezepte kennt und
schreibt sie gerne in die kommentare
ortrud über
stimmen
gibt es alles
komm ich trag das leben ihm die krücken
geht es gibt
ich komme immer zurück
kuratorin nicht kennen noch war auf
russische was klingt wie ein russisches
kinder leth ghosts mittel eher als zum
einen bin ich
glücklich bin ich hing schlaff blinkt
aber das ist ein anderes julia hat mir
einst beigebracht
juli schloss sind und zwar
kalinka kalinka kalinka war ja sarah
kalinka kalinka das schießen sie über
eine
wäre
da und dann sehe ich schon sehe ich
schon wie sie so tanzen soll ja ist ja
stellt sich ein verfolge
ich mache gerne großen druck immer auf
stimmt das aber nicht jetzt jetzt nicht
mehr sagt sie ausgewiesen
ich wollte euch nur noch das kinderlied
vorsingen das
lied von dahin werde mir san mir
allerhand tatsächlich welcher mitglied
ich glaube schon jetzt draußen auch hin
wenn am strom sanierer und ella könnte
tatsächlich auch ein bisschen russisch
weil sie sich immer gern mascha und der
bär auf russisch angeschaut haben und
dann diese suite dieses jahr samira kann
es aus wenn ich bei juve bin
ziemlich voll cool so sehr regen ja von
mir auch schon angesprochen und das muss
unsere meere hatte tatsächlich die
ersten drei jahre ihres lebens in
russischen akzent weil unsere nachbarn
charlotte war halo film und die hat mit
ihr immer gespielt und dann kam sanierer
und hat jahrelang das r so gerollt es
hat direkt bis zur verbindet weggebissen
und sie sind also zusammen auf seine
eigentlichen baustelle
in charlotte kam immer jeden alle jedes
jahr zu weihnachten vor weihnachten also
die haben vor weihnachten naja gut jetzt
essen unseren ab und machen jetzt aus
[Musik]